[Applause]
rogan is doing a podcast with tom segura
he's doing his podcast with tom segura
and segura opens it in a funny way and
uh then rogan gets to kind of sound off
and all the people that have been very
critical of uh the drugs that he took to
keep himself alive while he had covert
while he had covid run that clip al
the jurgen experience well well well it
i'm glad you're i'm glad you're well man
bro do i have to sue cnn i don't know i
don't know do you they're making [ __ ] up
they keep saying i'm taking horse
dewormer i literally got it from a
doctor it's an american company
it's a
they won the nobel prize in 2015 for use
in human beings yeah and
cnn is saying i'm taking horse dewormer
yeah what so they must know that that's
a lie there's a lot of people saying it
right but a lot of people can say it
okay like the internet says who cares
sure but cnn is saying it like jim
acosta i meant like like usa today a few
other
yeah and they're talking
about ivermectin
so what because i don't know i just saw
so much news about you i mean i would
talk to you and check on you and see if
you're all right and you're like
you you threw the kitchen sink at it you
said which was stuff that you know you
took
iv
drips and was it mono what mono
monoclonal antibodies and that what is
monoclonal antibodies the [ __ ] they gave
trump okay yeah um okay
do you think you should sue cnn it would
be fun
it would be fun and they did
i guess that's slander huh or libel if
it's written yeah yeah i'd be curious to
know what like the legal precedent is
because like
it's one of those things where like
technically
like they didn't clarify that he was
taking the one for human beings i mean
but that should be understood right yeah
but
in the right legal sense yeah so that's
what i'm wondering i wonder i don't i
doubt that there's a legal case i'm
almost done
but i understand what he's saying and
basically just to clarify for everybody
out there is that ivor mechtin is also
prescribed for human beings right and
they want a nobel peace prize for it now
ivor mexton is in much greater
quantities a horse dewormer right so
when you take it as a human you take
much smaller quantity but if you hate
joe rogan and you don't like his stance
on the vaccine you don't like his
politics of course you're going to use
every opportunity to make it look like
he takes [ __ ] horse bills right
so
cnn posting in other places i think
jamie was saying like usa today was
posting it these types of places it is
kind of crazy they would just run with
that because you know that they're
politically aligned with the opposition
of joe rogan so you know that they're
doing it to slander him but they found a
nice little caveat where they're allowed
to do that they're not even just
politically
aligned he threatens their kind of
existence a little bit which is this
whole alternate news source that people
go to podcasts in general have become
like this third-party news source that a
lot of people get their news from yeah
and we're not all getting it from npr or
the [ __ ] daily that alex listens to
yeah but so they're thinking this gotta
get this guy out i was off the daily i
could tell no i still do nah
you used to come through with facts bro
every single day
yeah i usually have to catch up like
towards the end of the week i'm not
listening to that you're listening to
two week old news yeah
we pulled out
yeah and then i would get too much
criticism for being liberal so
still do it you're like government look
at my underwear nah but i chill i chill
on it a little bit
i gotta give them some doses you know
something like that give it in doses yo
i i just think it's like let's just be
honest with what it is that'd be really
nice it'd be really nice if a newspaper
just came out we're like we don't like
this guy yeah so we're gonna bash him
and every opportunity we have we're
gonna bash him right you're like a
magician dude you can't reveal that it's
all [ __ ] nothing but it's so close
like there it's all so close i feel like
everybody's revealed it except them it's
like everybody it's what is it emperor's
new clothes it's like everybody knows
that they're naked but they refuse to
acknowledge that they're naked fox news
cnn all of them like we know you're
political leaning right stop saying
we're the truth yes say we're what makes
you feel good this is right-wing candy
left-wing canada you need some left-wing
cleaning come to us cause we're gonna
give you the left-wing feel-good story
every time i give credit to msnbc and
fox news i don't think they say they're
impartial i don't think they say they're
like fox's slogan is the real news
or the
it's in the slogan the place for the
truth
just tell us what the [ __ ] it is and i'd
be much happier because i go okay eight
o'clock i'm gonna read what the left got
to say nine o'clock i'm gonna read what
the right got to say boom i'm ready for
my day yeah i'll make my own decision
right here in the middle you don't have
to be in the middle it's [ __ ] hard we
tried to do it it murdered us we did it
for months and it was so [ __ ]
difficult to do to thread that needle
every single day i understand why both
of them don't they're basically comics
comics just come through with the
premise right they're like hey why are
dudes bad yeah boom tell us and then
other people go why are women bad boom
tell us right much easier
it's a much easier way to make a living
way more entertaining
huh it's way more entertaining to watch
yeah watching objective [ __ ] is boring
it's facts we're feelings we like
feelings dude that's why that's why
honestly fox news is so [ __ ]
entertaining because they will find a
way to just defend anything
like they will and somebody will come on
that show
and they will do it they will get
someone it doesn't matter what the [ __ ]
it is they will get someone to come out
there and be like yep totally understand
why he had to shoot those people in the
head yeah they're americans but they
stay in afghanistan too long they'll
just find a way to defend whatever the
[ __ ] it is and you're like oh how is he
gonna do it it feels like you're
watching a comic it really does and i
just care less about the left-wing
argument it's just not as interesting
just like i care less about the
left-wing argument from a comic right
like if they're going to go up there and
be like we need equal rights for
everybody easy okay yeah sure great yeah
obviously jump off the high dive that's
not right tell me why midges shouldn't
get library cards
make an argument that is so [ __ ]
absurd that i'm gonna want to keep
listening yeah so of course the
right-wing media is gonna run the
internet it's just way more digestible
it's fun it's sweet it's candy
even if you don't agree with it i wonder
how many people just watch it like let
me see what these crazy [ __ ]
say
i really wonder of course the left-wing
media [ __ ] is dying right because you
don't have trump to push back against
and
everything that joe rogan is your trump
you're reaching that's right they're
trying to make jokes rogan is your trump
your region and i was thinking about how
you don't get sued i guarantee you they
cleared that headline with uh with
whatever their legal department was can
we say this is technically a drug that
gets used on horses sometimes yeah so we
have it it's so funny to see like the
grifters who just like made all their
their money they made got all their
clicks off of trump just scrambled for
their new bad guy all right guys we're
gonna take a break from this exclusive
patreon clip because we are all adults
here and some of us need to choose
nicotine to relax focus or just unwind
after a long day and lucy nicotine is a
company that was created to help
nicotine users find a cleaner option and
feel better about the ways they consume
nicotine their latest product is slim
nicotine pouches which contain pure
synthetic nicotine and provide the same
satisfaction that nicotine users expect
without any tobacco at all okay get the
tobacco out of here lucy slim pouches
use the newest technology for
synthesizing pure nicotine in the lab
none of the tobacco all the nicotine
satisfaction lucy slim pouches include
both coconut oil and gum base to provide
a soft fluffy texture that enhances the
flavor and doesn't dry out your mouth
they come in three strengths four eight
and 12 milligrams and three exclusive
delicious flavors spearmint mango and
cool cider okay i'm telling you these
are absolutely [ __ ] delicious okay
they you get a little bit of that little
hit there's a little bit of high that
comes with it i don't even know even if
you don't use nicotine you got a family
remember you got a friend who's using
cigarettes filled with all that other
[ __ ]
dude use this you just tell them to get
off that tobacco and get on the lucy
it's simple okay it's 20 21. don't
compromise you're choosing your nicotine
products go with the newest tobacco-free
option from lucy so our listeners right
now can go to lucy.co and use the promo
code flagrant to get 20 off your order
of lucy slim pouches or any other lucy
products that's lucy l-u-c-y dot c-o and
use the promo code flagrant at checkout
also i have to give this disclaimer
warning this product contains
non-tobacco nicotine nicotine is an
addictive chemical lucy.co and be sure
to use that promo code flagrant now
let's get back to our exclusive patreon
clip you can get the full episode at
patreon.com flagrant2 join the [ __ ]
army let's do it
yeah yeah you need either a skill or a
background i mean the wright does it too
so much of course they all do it they'll
be like aoc is quiet and they're like
[ __ ] [ __ ]
omar do something marry your brother
critical races
exactly the right does it all the
[ __ ] time and you see right through
it now it's just really fun to see them
argue the wildest [ __ ] yeah you know
what yeah you see a youtube clip and
it's like tucker carlson sitting there
and he's like why the immigrants are
responsible for fentanyl and you're like
all right i'm gonna watch it i
agree going for it i want to see him get
but don't
there yeah this is a crazy sound just
guys
who watch comedy yes it's like uh what
is it what is it chris rock's a little
bit you know we gotta get rid of guns no
we gotta we gotta make bullets expensive
you're like i've got a decent i like
where we go with this where are we going
the more salacious the premise the more
interesting it's going to be chris rock
defended the [ __ ] columbine shooters
i think or something like that that's
three on three and a half coins
so maybe maybe it's just more
interesting to watch even though it's
not there but yeah you're right the
[ __ ] right griffs the left griffs and
they fall the [ __ ] apart when they don't
have someone to push back against yeah
and it's so true and everybody has to be
a threat to your [ __ ] existence
everybody aoc is a threat to freedom
donald trump is a threat to freedom this
country can't survive without they
vilify these people and now when you're
reaching that joe rogan like he's a
threat to [ __ ] the nation it's just
the craziest [ __ ] the guy literally just
brings on people who are experts in
their field and goes how do you feel
about this yeah they say it he has an
interesting discussion ask the questions
that we would ask because we're not
[ __ ] scientists that are dissecting
ivermectin every single day does it kill
me is it good for me can it help me if i
have bad cop you just ask these
questions and then all of a sudden
somehow he's some like villain go also
he said by the third day he felt almost
completely fine
something
none of us felt better with coleman
after three days so i was on a drip for
three straight [ __ ] days i was in a
goddamn hospital yeah mark got it twice
allegedly
i was depressed in the pool house
really though dude can those things go
together
like what a bougie [ __ ] this guy is
right i was depressed it sounds like a
drake lyric dude
tracks never call me the boathouse
certified
the router so number
get the wi-fi
shitty wi-fi yeah and you saw the
rolling stone retracted their article
about the ivermectin dude what did they
say how is there no punishment for this
yeah go on yeah so basically they
publish a story suggesting that at a
hospital in oklahoma they talked to a
doctor who was allegedly working there
and he told them that they were refusing
gunshot victims because they had so many
people that were overdosing on horse
strength ivermectin and then it got
published by the rolling stone and then
hundreds of other like news outlets like
both like just all over yeah and then
this is the best part they ended up
finding out that that doctor hasn't
worked there in a few months
but no one did the due diligence what
the [ __ ] is journalism doug i actually
don't yeah and i know slots they're only
fans
they're only fans for like covet news
that's all rolling stones only fans are
facts the only fans for facts but it's
not even facts lose all of them what's
the most salacious story where's the
candy where the sweets how do i get
where are the titties they're giving you
titties effects that's it and it's one
thing when you're a lot of them are fake
on like [ __ ] instagram and you're
like hey i'm doing my news thing here's
my opinion on this or here's what i
think of this or like here's an
established news brand and you're
telling saying you're the truth and on
top of that you're hiding behind your
brand yeah so you're not like a person
putting your neck out as an independent
journalist being like yo here's what i
think this is
you're just a
like a faceless entity this giant
institution that's basically saying like
here's information and they do nothing
to correct the misinformation they put
they put the header saying like
technically this is but they've done the
comparison tweets like the the the tweet
that says that the hospital is turning
away gunshot patients for people that
are oding on ivermectin gets 10 000
retweets the header that says they
[ __ ] up the story gets 20. max so
you're not really doing the due
diligence and here's the thing they
can't
because their business is run by
interest and retweets nobody's
retweeting that the story was fake yeah
you're retweeting that the story
confirms your beliefs which are
ivermectin people taking that to be good
and beat coveted bad yeah right
um but they're eroding their own trust
slowly and they can't help it you you
have to do it
real quick on that
it makes me feel like people exactly it
makes me feel like people don't care
about trust i cared about i care about
trust i used to think that's what it was
like i can trust that this place is
going to give me the truth right but i
think people just care about feeling
good right right so it's just like how
can you confirm my feelings you don't
need to be the most trusted news source
you need some of those trusted sources
going to confirm my feelings is joe
rogan a bad guy who's going to tell me
he's bad today yes i'll go to you and i
guess call because i was thinking this
the term news inherently it should be
truth but i think now we don't even care
the news news is just something to uh
echo what we like echo what we feel yeah
and the same thing happened on the right
side with the the dogs in afghanistan do
you remember those
so no tell me basically there are all
these dog penalties oh i saw this this
is
the same same exact thing so such a
right wing news this is great yeah so
basically there's all these dogs there
are military canine animals that are all
in these different kennels sitting in
like what looks like an airport hangar
yeah and there's probably like 10
candles all like kind of stacked on each
other and then the picture got posted on
the internet and then the title that
came with it is u.s troops and joe biden
are leaving these dogs to die in the
kennels at the hands of the taliban yeah
i got sent that by right-wing friends
[ __ ] frauds dirt and if you do have a
dog you care about dogs right you're
like how the [ __ ] is this animal duty
it's the most important pieces it's the
worst thing ever like it kills you in a
way that like no other crime does it's
like you're gonna leave a dog to die
starve in a cage it's like the most
inhumane thing you could even think yeah
and then pentagon came out and they were
like yeah this isn't true this is an
erroneous report like we're not going to
just leave dogs in a kennel like we
would euthanize them or whatever but
like they're like we're not going to
leave them there to starve women did
they kill them no no they said they said
no they said they took them back okay so
they did take them back they were just
like it makes no sense so they didn't
even
check the story and that's the thing is
that's a perfect example it's like a
girl taking a picture where she looks
skinnier and her tits look fatter than
they actually really do she's like oh
this is going on a gramp
all pictures every picture yeah exactly
and it's like that's what that's what
fox is what did fox post it uh everyone
posted it but yeah every right-wing news
source right into all the right-wing
grifters and i got sent that by a friend
who's the number one don't trust the
media they're all full [ __ ] but he's a
right-wing [ __ ] going crazy and
now this has to be a fact it's what i
feel because you're exactly cause you're
waking up going why is biting bad yeah
and they're going all these news sources
going please tell me why he's bad he
doesn't like dogs he just left the dog
oh he served in the military's like i
can't believe i wake up in pain every
day for this like this [ __ ] was
going off you know why uh you know why
they ran with that story what i bet you
they ran with that story because the
cuomo leaving his dog
at like the ghost oh cruise cruise
cruise right no cuomo left his dog at
the governor's palace or whatever
apparently allegedly i don't even know
if that's true but that story
murdered because everybody was [ __ ]
cuomo you had the left and the right
saying [ __ ] cuomo right because the left
was all like how dare he touch women and
the right's like uh he's a democrat
but both of them are like we care about
dogs right that story murdered i
guarantee there is somebody at the
right-wing news sources who are just
sitting there like oh we got a dog story
yeah you're running back
running yeah also crazy
when cruz ran to cancun he left his dog
everybody's like how the [ __ ] you leave
your dog yeah
he's hit bruh dog stories hit you
differently man that [ __ ] sucks actually
the dog stories might be the stories
that actually bring us together because
they're the everybody cares about a
[ __ ] dog
every human has done some shitty things
a dog don't know no better he gets a
[ __ ] on a carpet worse thing he does
yeah
dove loves dogs man that's his favorite
thing don't get me started
with those going out in new york
stealing your dog this is a three times
a week situation that we're in what's
that borrowing the dog you're going to
win three times a week yeah just make
sure it shits so that i don't have to
wake my girl up in the middle of the
night the hardest part was making it not
touched you need to give me the dog with
zannies no i'm going to give you the uh
the uh what's it called thing
what the zapper oh i think like zanny's
like the drug yeah yeah we need that
thought
bottle and some water just shoot it no
his girl actually they had the little
collar and she's like i don't think you
want to walk around with that thing so
the animal they'll be judged
i want to be judged yeah like
charlemagne always says like uh the
truth isn't important when the lie is
more entertaining like it's that's just
life at this point son what if for like
six months
we all just told the truth or not even
we like don't [ __ ] trust us for the
truth trust us for fun we're going to
make every story the most fun please
feelings
don't come to us for the news come to us
to hear the funniest takes about a story
that's what we're going to do okay and
sometimes we'll fail miserably in that
but we are going to talk about we're
going to give you feelings no facts what
up people you just watch a clip from our
weekly patreon episode you can support
the flagrancy you can support this
unapologetic
unfiltered uncensored content that we
drop weekly on our patreon at
patreon.com flagrant2 you want to go
join you should because it's a top 10
patreon in the [ __ ] world that's
right for a good reason go check out why
at patreon.comflagrant2
all right peace